ceo maurice benvenuti in questo
nuovissimo allora ormai è risaputo non
esiste una festività senza un top flop
di marina quindi anche per questa pasqua
mi sono sentita in dovere di proporvi la
mia pasqua top e flop
in particolare voglio raccontarvi due
episodi di pasqua assolutamente flop e
uno di pasqua top
iniziamo subito la mia prima pasqua flop
poi ce ne sono state altre sempre uguali
adesso capirete per te risale alle
elementari alimentari andavo dalle suore
e dalle suore puntualmente a pasqua si
faceva la recita di pasqua dove ognuno
di noi di tutte le classi di prima
seconda terza quarta quinta interpretava
un personaggio inutile dirvi che se eri
femmina il personaggio più ambito era
chiaramente maria
inutile dirvi che era il mio sogno fare
maria inutile dirvi che non ho mai fatto
perché mia mamma aveva avuto la
brillante idea di portarmi a tagliare i
capelli da una scuola di parrucchieri e
chiaramente mi è capitata l'apprendista
negata proprio che penso che sia stato
il suo unico giorno di lavoro dove che è
stata centrata mia rasato i capelli e
l'ho chiesto un caschetto cantonata casa
coi capelli a spazzola per colpa di
questo taglio come dire poco femminile
la parte di maria non l'ho mai potuta
fare perché chiaramente c'era la mia
compagna di classico i capelli fino alle
ginocchia che era perfetta e voi direte
va beh avrei fatto un'altra parte
comunque carino volete sapere che parti
ho fatto per tutti i cinque minuti
[Musica]
l'istigatrice del popolo e voi vi direte
ma che parte
niente devo andare praticamente tra la
folla e dire questa frase portate
barabba votate barabba questo è quello
che dice allora sono tra documentari
perché non ricordavo più niente
praticamente barabba era come riportato
in alcuni manoscritti del vangelo un
ebreo appartenente al partito degli
zeloti detenuto dai romani a gerusalemme
assieme ad alcuni ribelli negli stessi
giorni della passione di gesù detto il
cristo e fondatore del cristianesimo
egli è bene liberato dalla folla ed è lì
che interveniva io l'istigatrice della
folla quindi praticamente io dicevo
votate barabba per liberarlo e penso di
sì e luisa come parte cioè mi veniva a
letto con una bella parte e roero contro
gesù quindi forse con me c'erano questi
due appunto ebrei che dovevano uno dei
due doveva essere crocifisso secondo me
e quindi io dicevo voltate barabba per
non concepirlo quindi per per salvarlo e
nomination nomination
vabbè chiusa questa infelice parentesi
delle recite scolastiche passerei a una
par con un po più recente ma non
recentissima forse sei anni fa vivevo
ancora torino è praticamente non avevo
programmi per pasco perché ero in un
momento un po di ribellione non volevo
passarlo con la famiglia e volevo fare
qualcosa di alternativo
volevo fare una tasca un po alternativa
perché come dice il detto natale con i
tuoi pasqua con chi vuoi
quindi io e la mia migliore amica dei
tempi siamo guardate abbiamo detto ma
cosa facciamo per quasco facciamo
qualcosa che non fa nessuno
andiamo alle terme
ecco rivedibile concetto di non lo fa
nessuno perché vi ricordo che tutte
prese bene pronti a rilassarci a
staccare dal mondo arriviamo alle terme
c'era la coda fuori c'è una cosa mai
vista prima tutti quell'anno password
non dati alle terme quindi non vi
consiglio di andare mai all'eterna
pasqua in quel periodo ero innamorata
persa di un ragazzo quindi ci sentivamo
ogni tanto uscivamo però sapete quella
situazione in cui comunque non lui non
si espone più di tanto quindi non puoi
dire stiamo insieme a una frequentazione
nella quale io ero completamente sotto
un treno
arriviamo alle terme io mi metto il mio
costume eccetera eccetera
quando si fa le terme non so voi ma io
non è che mi mettono qualcosa sul più
bello e metto costume che anche se lo
rovino
sono tranquilla praticamente era un
costume di merda e mi sono molto pentita
di questa scelta
quando appena entrata davanti a me vedo
grazie a dio lui non mi ha visto lui con
una ragazza ed è subito panico
a quel punto ho detto allora o me ne
frego anche se sto rosicando un sacco e
continuo la mia pasqua bellissima alle
terme con altre 40 miliardi di persone
la mia migliore amica
oppure trovo una soluzione cosa faccio
quando sui suoi social e vedo che lui
ladri faricciotti do che avrebbe passato
la pasquali quindi mi sono fatta il
viaggio paranoico damon è che questo
pensa che io sia andata alle terme per
pedinarlo perché i veramente era da
stalker numero uno quindi cosa ho fatto
dopo aver pagato 50 euro di entrata di
terme già vestita come già col mio
costumino pronta per tuffarmi
nell'idromassaggio ho convinto la mia
amica ad andarcene perché non potevo
rischiare di fare una figura del genere
non potevo numero veramente drammatica
ma passiamo argomento top e sono sicuro
che di scendere una lacrima perché è un
momento molto recente
si tratta di due anni fa e come tanti di
voi già sapranno due anni fa
mi sono fidanzata con salvo cosa è
successo due anni fa a pasqua è successo
che ero tornata a vivere momentaneamente
a torino perché finita l'università non
trovavo lavoro e quindi per non pesare
appunto sui miei chiedo non pagare un
affitto a vuoto me ne sono tornata a
torino è però ormai avevo tutti gli
amici qua dell'università c per accedere
quindi venivo spesso qua a milano e
dormivo a casa dei miei amici quindi
anche quella pasqua
proprio come quella del mio della mia
pasqua flop non avevo voglia insomma di
passarlo in famiglia volevo un attimo
dell'ira milano magari di festeggiare
fare qualcosa di diverso e quindi ho
sentito questo mio compagno
all'università ex compagno sita proprio
mal avevano finito vita che mi dice
marina guarda se ti va bene anche su mia
sorella dalla sicilia siamo un po qua
faccio una pasquetta qua sono anche
degli altri amici che insomma verranno a
fare la pasqua qua siamo tutti insieme
ci divertiamo da ieri
io non avendo tante altre opzioni perché
tutte le mie amiche o lo facciamo ancora
famiglia oi fidanzati io come al solito
ero single ho detto va bene ci sto
quindi prendo il mio treno vengo a
milano prima cosa ti faccio ancora prima
di posare le valigie e andare in centro
a comprarmi dei nuovi vestiti e li sento
il mio amico che mi dice guarda c'è mia
sorella in giro ben capito lei così vi
vedete tornare venite a casa insieme che
con un mio amico tutto va bene becco sua
sorella in centro e mi accorgo che il
suo amico io lo conoscevo già e l'avevo
conosciuto in sicilia perché la maggior
parte dei miei
diversità ri era veniva dalla sicilia e
quindi puntualmente io quasi tutte le
estati scendeva giù e andavo a trovarli
e quindi conoscevo anche comunque altri
loro amici che non vivevano abbiano però
scendevano come tutti i fuori sede in
sicilia d'estate e avevo conosciuto
questo ragazzo in discoteca ma proprio
tipo ciao piace piacere fine molto
carino molto bello
ai tempi era fidanzato io pure e niente
quindi lago conosciuto dopo tipo 12 anni
non mi ricordo chi io
lui non lo ammette però come era stato
lui ad aggiungere mi su facebook perché
io proprio per principio odio aggiungere
i ragazzi su facebook cioè mi sento
veramente nelle provata quindi non l'ho
mai fatto accettavo solo le richieste di
quelli che se mi sembravano carini lui
appena l'ho visto lo avevo già
conosciuto l'ho accettato e quindi da lì
non è che ci sentivamo prof 6 ogni tanto
ci mettevamo un like e tattico questa
persona era salvo che quando lo vedo
davanti però anche tu qui bene io non ne
sapevo nulla infatti poi mi sono mezzo
incazzata col mio amico perché le
toccava potevi dire di canali già lo
conoscevo
nel senso potevo decidere se venire o
meno da te per pasqua
magari non sarei venuto ok
detto questo lo vedo ci salutiamo
eccetera eccetera
e poi andiamo a casa
praticamente cosa è successo che per non
mi ricordo cinque sei giorni a settimana
abbiamo anche una specie di grande
fratello perché eravamo io il mio amico
sua sorella salvo e i due coinquilini
del nemico e le rispettive fidanzate o
comunque amici dei due con corini
quindi abbiamo fatto praticamente un
grande fratello in questi giorni di
grande fratello a pasqua pasquetta non
mi ricordo ho avuto la brillanti le a
dire ragazzi oggi cucino io e già li
dovevano aver paura perché ho detto già
ci piace chiamo io salgo se lo prendo
per la gola come tutti gli uomi calder
ai miei piedi o faccio cucino mio piatto
forte che sono gli gnocchi ai formaggi
non voce la pentola cioè eravamo lì
tutti che chiacchieravamo erano si
stavano facendo un certo punto si chiama
la puzza di bruciato immensa ha preso
fuoco la pentola cioè con una figura di
merda atroce
niente c'era creazione io facevo latina
dove sempre uno due tre quattro giorni e
poi noto al momento del primo bacio
primo bacio è stato molto molto molto
molto difficile perché lui voleva
baciare meglio testina testina destino e
strade stina
chiaramente devo fare un pò la ritrosa
non potevo cedere così e alla fine c'è
stato questo primo bacio è praticamente
nessuno aveva voglia di uscirne vogliamo
andare a ballare sai fare un po di night
life nessuno le voci e quindi non ho mai
capito se l'hanno fatto apposta per
lasciarci soli oppure se era veramente
se non avevamo veramente vogliono uscire
se hai fatto che io stavo prendiamo la
macchina l'enjoy e ce ne andiamo in un
locale in corso como
chi le amicizie andiamo a bere nord ma
io lo chiamavo amo perché io chiamo amo
tutti eravamo in macchina continuo dire
amo cioè lo trattavo un po tipo così
tipo da amico perché io comunque gli
amici li chiamo così duro e ha ceduto
luis igienica mano cosa scusa io chiamo
chi voglio io chiamo amo tutti quindi
fatto notare denti
momento anno arriviamo in questo locale
mente beviamo sente la musica così e ci
conoscevamo un po c'è parti ci
raccontavamo chi eravamo e cosa volevamo
dalla vita al giorno punto questo
momento filosofico si avvicina una che
si pianta davanti a me ci abita le
spalle e si mette a parlare con lui
chiedendole un accendino
il commovente marina doveva scegliere
tra ucciderla oppure fare la parte di
quella che comunque non era interessata
era con un'amica aveva alcun problema
non l'ho uccisa
chiaramente poi momento io ho avuto la
brillante idea di e ligia senti allora
non so come andrà a finire tra di noi
magari non ci vedremo mai più
però sappi che avevo detto così se io
fossi la tua fidanzata lo sai che in
questo momento con la tipa cioè avrebbe
finito di esistere
e allora lui se ne sa ridere perché
anche se io in girata così comunque era
una mezza roba tipo che ero gelosa o no
che non so da dove mi è uscita però io
sono così sono sincera quindi avrei
detto cavolo se stavamo insieme queste
si mette acqua davanti a spostava
diciamo senti in via ci sono anch'io
cioè ferite non accennino quest'anno
aggravanti avete trovati davanti
ok è di 3 watt in aria non è il posto
per te quindi già avevo capi aveva
capito già la tipologia di ragazzo ecco
e diciamo che con questa uscita salvo ha
iniziato a capire insomma che non mi era
indifferente anche perché dai miei
comportamenti
cercavo di fargli capire che non era
coinvolta no sai facevo testina così c'è
perché io sono un po diffidente
all'inizio
non mi sciolgo subito lì non so perché
forse era stato l'alcol e l'ho buttata
li tieni questo è quello che penso e io
ti può forse gelo dopo si sono pentite
però ormai dado era tratto quello che è
successo dopo che è stato anche
abbastanza complicato ci stara dovrei
fare un video lungo e raccontarvi tutto
nei dettagli quindi la chiudiamo qui e
ne parleremo più avanti ve lo prometto
che prima o poi vi racconterò tutto
tutto tutta la storia
detto questo spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
cliccate sulla campanella vicino al
tasso d'iscrizione per ricevere una
notifica tutte le volte che pubblicherò
un nuovo video e soprattutto seguite vi
su tutti gli altri social instagram
facebook e musicali io vi mando un
bacione e vi faccio tanti tanti tanti
auguri di una buona pasqua ci vediamo al
prossimo miglior adoro
[Musica]